mittlerweile sind allein im osten der
demokratischen republik kongo 2000
menschen an ebola gestorben weitere 3000
menschen sind an dem heimtückischen
virus erkrankt jetzt hat
bundesaußenminister heiko maas das ebola
gebiet besucht und versprochen das land
im kampf gegen die epidemie finanziell
zu unterstützen außerdem hat ein
forschungsteam zwei antikörpertherapien
gegen ebola erfolgreich getestet kann
die krankheit jetzt endlich aufgehalten
werden den krieg zum science fiction
jetzt täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocken nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
wir können der ausbreitung des virus
nicht weiter tatenlos zusehen
so hieß es von bundesaußenminister heiko
maas bei seinem besuch im osten der
demokratischen republik kongo am vierten
september schon seit 13 monaten
versuchen teams aus helferinnen und
helfern die lage in den griff zu
bekommen
doch die seuche ist gefährlich und das
virus breitet sich weiter aus
mittlerweile ist klar dass dieser ebola
ausbruch der schlimmste nach der
verheerenden epidemie in westafrika es
2014 2015 fordert das virus hier mehr
als 11.000 tote
die situation in der demokratischen
republik kongo ist jedenfalls extrem
angespannt denn es ist nicht nur die
ebola epidemie jedem land zu schaffen
macht auch die sicherheitslage macht es
den helferinnen und helfern schwer
es geht um bodenschätze um die
bewaffnete rebellen gnadenlos
gegeneinander kämpfen selbst die
helferinnen und helfer können sich nicht
sicher fühlen hinzu kommt dass manche
ebola opfer die dringend benötigte hilfe
nicht annehmen denn die bevölkerung ist
misstrauisch
das liegt an gerüchten denen zufolge
erste teams blut und körperteile klauen
wollen um damit hexerei zu betreiben
zudem kritisieren hilfsorganisationen
dass die kontrollmaßnahmen am flughafen
goma mangelhaft seien seitdem mitte juli
in der kongolesischen großstadt der
erste ebola fall bestätigt wurde wird
allen passagieren fieber gemessen
doch nun hat sich herausgestellt dass
bei manchen betroffenen an den
kontrollposten dramatischer weise keine
infektion festgestellt worden war
und das obwohl diese menschen bereits
infiziert war der internationale verbund
verschiedener hilfs und
entwicklungsorganisation oxfam fordert
deswegen bessere ausrüstung und
trainings für die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter
gesundheitsdienste bundesaußenminister
heiko maas hat die dramatische situation
erkannt und hat versprochen mit
verantwortlichen der un über finanzielle
hilfen zu sprechen
trotz großer anstrengungen sind die
fortschritte noch nicht so wie man es
sich gewünscht hat bislang sind es vier
millionen euro die deutsche
bundesregierung der ebola nothilfe
direkt beigesteuert hat deutschland ist
zudem am fonds der
weltgesundheitsorganisation gho der
weltbank und den vereinten nationen
beteiligt und zwar mit einem
millionenbetrag auch dieses geld wird
zumindest teilweise für die ebola hilfe
verwendet wir haben hier einen krieg zum
science fiction ja immer wieder über die
neuesten entwicklungen zum thema
gesprochen ebola ist ein fieber das in
rund der hälfte der fälle zum tod führt
es beginnt relativ harmlos wie eine
grippe aber im weiteren verlauf fangen
die opfer an überall zu bluten und
sterben schließlich an multiplem
organversagen übertragen wird die
krankheit meistens von sogenannten
reservoir wirken
das sind wildtiere die gejagt und
gegessen werden durch die abholzung von
wäldern rücken menschen immer näher an
diese populationen heran durch den
verzehr von buschfleisch wie etwa
flughunde affen oder stachelschweine
kommt es dann meistens zum ausbruch der
seuche und dann wird sie von mensch zu
mensch übertragen eine klinische studie
die seit november 2008 10 vorn
durchgeführt wurde und die wirksamkeit
von vier medikamenten gegen ebola
untersucht hat merkt jetzt aber einen
kleinen hoffnungsschimmer denn zwei der
vier untersuchten medikamente schnitten
gut ab die sterblichkeitsrate sank im
durchschnitt auf etwa 30 prozent von
diesem ergebnis berichtet unter anderem
das national institute of health wenn
ebola betroffenen nicht behandelt werden
liegt die sterblichkeit zwischen 60 und
67 prozent
die beiden erfolgreichen wirkstoffe mit
der bezeichnung re n b 3 und b 114 wenn
jetzt auch außerhalb der studie
eingesetzt und eben oder patienten und
patientinnen verabreicht die therapie
setzt auf die gabe von antikörpern das
sind eiweiße die das immunsystem
normalerweise selbst herstellt und
krankheitserreger aufhält die antikörper
für die getesteten mittel bilden sich an
ein eiweiß auf der oberfläche des
ebola-virus so verhindern sie dass der
erreger in die körperzellen eindringen
dazu der direktor des national institute
of allergy and infectious disease
anthony fauci wir können jetzt sagen
dass 90 prozent der patienten nach der
behandlung geheilt sind die studie an
sich wurde frühzeitig gestoppt damit die
anderen beiden medikamente die die
sterblichkeitsrate nur schwach
verringert hatten nicht mehr eingesetzt
werden rund 680 patienten und
patientinnen wurden in der schule
aufgenommen deren offizielle
veröffentlichung für herbst 2009 10
geplant ist der medizinstudent hat ein
video dazu gemacht indem die krankheit
noch mal medizinisch natürlich nochmal
deutlich detaillierter erklärt wird
anklicken also hier anschauen und der
medizinstudent abonnieren meine
empfehlung auf jeden fall ist dann
bleibt dran